heute sprechen wir über dinge die man
wissen muss wenn man zum ersten mal nach
deutschland kommt natürlich gibt es viel
wissenswertes aber wir sprechen heute
über ein paar einfache themen die euch
dabei helfen können kulturschocks und
überraschungen zu vermeiden wenn ihr zum
ersten mal in deutschland sei los geht's
unser erstes thema ist die sprache denn
je nachdem wohin ihr in deutschland
fahrt könnt ihr ganz unterschiedliche
sprachliche erfahrungen machen wollt ihr
zum beispiel unbedingt deutsch sprechen
dann könnt ihr wahrscheinlich in einer
kleineren stadt besser deutsch lernen
als zum beispiel in berlin wo sowieso
viele touristen und viele internationale
besucher sind und wenn ihr unbedingt
englisch sprechen wollte weil ihr noch
gar kein deutsch kennt dann seid ihr auf
jeden fall in einer der größeren städte
gut aufgehoben denn leute können euch da
ganz gut verstehen und ihr könnt auch im
zweifelsfall immer jemanden finden der
euch helfen kann zum übersetzen
generell meine erfahrung ist dass man in
vielen restaurants und auch in vielen
geschäften also dort wo die leute im
service arbeiten
englisch kann zumindest englisch
verstehen kann wenn es jedoch um
öffentliche orte geht oder zum beispiel
öffentliche verkehrsmittel behörden dann
würde ich nicht unbedingt damit rechnen
dass die leute auch englisch sprechen
unser nächstes thema ist bargeld in
vielen länder kann man einfach reisen
und überall mit der kreditkarte zahlen
aber nicht in deutschland
die deutschen bevorzugen tatsächlich
ganz oft noch das gute alte bargeld denn
sie halten es für vertrauenswürdig und
so kommt es dass 2018 bei uns das erste
jahr war in dem es mehr online zahlungen
gab als bargeldzahlungen wenn man sich
vorstellt was das heißt dann kann man
sich vorstellen wie viele zahlungen in
deutschland immer noch war getätigt
werden
wenn ihr also ein restaurant geht oder
abends in einer
nehmt immer bargeld mit denn es kann
sein dass er nicht mit einer karte
bezahlen könnt ihr müsst also immer zum
geldautomaten gehen ein kleiner tipp am
besten geht ihr aber zu einer richtigen
bank denn diese automaten die so in der
wand sind oder in so kleinen geschäften
die sind meistens viel teurer
[Musik]
in vielen ländern ist das wirklich
unvorstellbar aber in deutschland haben
sonntags alle geschäfte geschlossen
wirklich alle wenn ihr also einkaufen
wollt dann müsst ihr an einem anderen
tag planen einkaufen zu gehen
die gründe sind verschieden es hat etwas
mit der christlichen tradition zu tun
aber vor allem auch mit
arbeitnehmerrechten und dem schutz der
arbeitnehmer es sollen nämlich alle
menschen am sonntag einen ruhetag haben
und die möglichkeit ihre familien zu
sehen wenn ihr trotzdem etwas kaufen
müsst dann könnt ihr meistens in
bahnhöfen geschäfte finden die auf haben
oder tankstellen finden
in deutschland kann man tatsächlich auf
der straße alkohol trinken und für
manche von euch ist das eine positive
überraschung und für manche von euch ist
das vielleicht sogar ein bisschen
bedrohlich
macht euch keine sorgen wenn ihr alkohol
auf der straße sieht das ist tatsächlich
in deutschland normal würde ich sagen
die leute sind daran gewöhnt und viele
leute verhalten sich auch trotzdem ganz
normal auch wenn sie in der
öffentlichkeit trinken
also wenn ihr nach deutschland kommt
übertreibt nicht je nachdem wo ihr
herkommt solltet ihr damit rechnen dass
deutsche manchmal ein bisschen kälter
sind deutsche sind keine großen freunde
des small talks und manchmal finden es
deutsche sogar komisch mit fremden zu
reden
ich kenne das zum beispiel aus den orten
wo ich gelebt habe
man begegnet sich sogar manchmal im
gleichen haus und sagt sich nicht hallo
und ich weiß dass viele von euch das
komisch finden ich finde dass zum
beispiel positiv wenn ich in
andere länder fahren und ich mich
einfach mit fremden menschen auf der
straße oder im supermarkt unterhalte
deutsche sind aber nicht unfreundlich
sie haben nur eine andere art der nähe
und das solltet ihr wissen das heißt es
ist ein bisschen schwieriger sie
kennenzulernen
aber wenn ihr sie erst mal kennenlernt
sind sie genauso freundlich wie andere
menschen ein sehr simples thema aber
trotzdem vergisst man es oft
stromadapter so sieht so in unsere
stecker aus und wenn ihr nach
deutschland kommt braucht ihr einen
adapter damit dass in die steckdose
passt auch das ist ein wichtiges thema
trinkgeld in deutschland gibt man
ungefähr zehn prozent trinkgeld wenn man
im restaurant ist aber auch wenn man an
einer bar ist und ich habe das schon
miterlebt dass es manchmal zu
unangenehmen situationen kommt wenn
jemand aus einem anderen land kommt der
nicht weiß dass man in deutschland
trinkgeld gibt und dann die deutsche
kellnerin oder der deutsche kellner aber
auf das trinkgeld wartet also jetzt
wisst ihr bescheid wir haben übrigens
schon mal ein video dazu gemacht das
findet ihr hier
deutsche lieben regeln und vor allem
lieben deutsche verkehrsregeln und das
ist etwas womit ihr unbedingt rechnen
sollte wenn ihr nach deutschland kommt
denn tatsächlich nehmen deutsche die
verkehrsregeln sehr ernst und ich würde
sagen sie nähmen sie sogar ernster als
viele leute in anderen ländern deutsche
mögen ist die regeln einzuhalten denn
sie denken das trägt zur effizienz und
zur effektivität bei und sie erinnern
sogar andere menschen daran die regeln
einzuhalten und das ist wirklich
verrückt wenn
zum ersten mal in deutschland sei ein
großer fehler den ich immer wieder sehe
ist zum beispiel dass touristen auf
einem radweg stehen mit ihrem koffer und
sie denken sich nichts dabei in vielen
ländern gibt es gar keine radwege doch
in deutschland kommen sofort die
fahrradfahrer und sind wütend warum
steht der fußgänger auf meinem fahrrad
weg und blockiert mich und es kann dann
sogar passieren dass sie euch an
klingeln oder rufen hey das ist ein
fahrradweg bei unserem nächsten tipp
geht es um eure reiseplanung wie ihr
vielleicht schon gehört habt sind
deutsche sehr organisiert sogar ein
bisschen zu organisiert und auch wenn es
um reisen geht mögen es deutsche sehr
weit im voraus zu planen und viele
ticketing systeme sind auch darauf
ausgelegt dass ihr etwas günstiger
bekommt umso früher bucht und das geht
zum beispiel gilt es auch für bahn
fahren wenn ihr zum beispiel eure reise
bucht mit bands oder hotels dann
versucht nicht spontan morgens zum
bahnhof zu gehen und entwickelt zu
kaufen denn ein ticket kann bis zu fünf
mal teurer sein wenn man ist am gleichen
tag bucht und wenn man es sechs wochen
vorher bucht oder zwei monate vorher
kann zum beispiel eine strecke die sonst
100 euro kostet nur noch 20 euro kosten
das war unser video mit tipps für alle
von euch die ihre erste reise nach
deutschland planen und wenn ihr bei
eurer ersten reise nach deutschland auch
möglichst viel deutsch sprechen wollt
dann empfehlen wir euch unbedingt unsere
app ceiling siedlung ist gerade dafür
ausgerichtet für leute die selbst
organisiert und strukturiert deutsch
lernen möchten von zu hause und wir
haben jetzt schon viele nachrichten
bekommen von leuten von euch die
siedlung im app store gesucht haben
und tatsächlich gibt es noch nicht im
app store als download allerdings
arbeiten wir gerade unter hochdruck
daran und das wird in den nächsten
monaten kommen
die app funktioniert allerdings bereits
als web-app im browser das heißt ihr
könnt einfach ceiling dot com
eurem handy eintippen sowohl bei iphones
als auch bei android als auch bei
windows und dann seht ihr die app und
sie ist schon voll funktion aber auch
auf dem handy druck recht das mal an wir
freuen uns wenn ihr das ausprobiert und
wir freuen uns wenn wir uns nächste
woche wieder sehen und ist an
[Musik]